[Music]
[Music]
Luke dominate here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we are
starting our 2018 world tour well guys
I'm doing something that I've wanted to
do for a long time I've taken a month
off of work and we are going to pretty
much travel the world I have 29 airline
tickets and we are going to be going
crazy we've got some amazing things
planned and I'm gonna bring you guys
along for the ride are you guys excited
to do our world tour yeah
holy mackerel look at that pile of
luggage
[Music]
[Music]
we made it we're live we're here all
right Tommy we moved to Salt Lake City
but are you excited
glad to see grandma grandpa awesome it's
gonna be off the hook Shelly off the
hook those kids wake up early I think
we're just gonna take it nice and easy
go go visit a relative drive around a
little bit hang out nice just to have a
relaxing lazy Sunday morning Nathan are
you ready for church Tommy are you ready
for church yeah oh look at that that is
a wad cute baby look at those little
cake boobies like daddy did you have fun
at church what did you do at church
what are you guys up to trying to keep
Sunday pretty low-key but one of the
things we are going to do is we can go
up to down Iaido
and visit my uncle I haven't seen him in
five years he hasn't met Nathan and
Jacob yet well there is local diner
health our second state in our room we
made it oh my back is sore
[Applause]
so we're out in the middle of nowhere
here in Chesterfield Idaho it's an old
pioneer town a ghost town of sorts
because zombies here and vampires here
and ghost to ghost town means there's
lots of ghosts yeah check it out this is
the old tiding office I'll check it out
so you guys can see that inside it's
restored - they got the old stove and
they got the picture of the Prophet
Joseph Smith and the Prophet Brigham
Young over there in the corner yeah is
that cool yeah this point Tommy so
apparently this town was one of the many
towns along the Oregon Trail so
hopefully none of us will die of cholera
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this right there that's a chamber pot
that's for pooping bro in the middle of
the night if you need to use the potty
you don't want to go out to the outhouse
you use the chamber pot right there so
you're on point that's the potty wanna
go check out the potty cool thing about
this place is it's the families the
ancestors of these original pioneers
that are fixing this up and restoring
this entire town this isn't a park or
anything this is just people preserving
history all people used to live in the
town Butch Cassidy man actually butch
Cassidy's got his roots in Utah
apparently he stole the horses of the
guys that founded this town
all right guys hold on tight
there's a lot more fun than writing on
the inside of the car yeah check this
out his old dugout cabin here got the
outhouse in the back cobblestone they
dig into the hillside like a hobbit hole
then you plant grass on the roof come
out come back here guys get away from
the sprinkler you want to ride in the
back all the way back to Salt Lake
that's not happening
stay three and we've got some today who
wants to do for breakfast and he says be
poopy and eat eyeball soup I think I
better be the one calling the shots for
breakfast today got the fresh fruit
crepes
we got the fresh fruit french toast
buckwheat blueberry pancakes bacon
waffles we got fruit pancakes and then a
bunch of baked our sausage like that
looks pretty good huh are you guys
excited to go up to the cabin back in
the bag see
[Music]
yeah that little place lied you guys
having fun yeah you only go faster
a bear is gone and scraped scrape the
tree
here's his claw marks on this side and
his claw marks on this side and these
you marked his territory look at this
view guys look at this
not too shabby huh oh look at that
go ahead big a wish to dummy is huge
look at the size of those seeds all
right
get buckled up in there hey Beckett did
you have a good time
oh yeah I'm gonna brush you Oh your nose
is dirty - let's brush your nose here we
are at Salem Lake in Utah Becca and her
parents might come and join us and do a
little picnicking later yeah you got a
bunch of bites
come on kit whoa don't wanna get alright
hold on there no it's not a rainbow
trout check this out
Holly mackerel what's the white bass
doing here
I'll get thrown back having fun though
there's Tommy warming up in the Sun
there's Nathan's just doing whatever
Tommy does you guys tired are you hungry
did you use a hamburger and some ice
cream feeling better all right guys come
follow me
you guys like this play set those people
give you that sure that's really nice of
them well the kids have had a good time
but we are sunburned and tired and it is
time to go home because we need to pack
we're leaving for Las Vegas than Japan
tomorrow morning's wait I'm looking for
Nathan has anyone seen Nathan where what
I'm wearing a Nathan it's the latest
fashion everyone's going to be doing it
this year me Mommy and Tommy here are
gonna head off towards Las Vegas and
then eventually to Japan now Tommy do
you know how to say hello in Japanese
how do you say ninja Japanese ninja I
[Music]
wish we could bring Nathan and Jacob
with us to Japan but Becca's going for a
work conference if she's gonna be in
meetings most the time and having three
boys in Japan it's a little bit much and
I miss my boy but we'll be back soon and
you're gonna have fun with Grandma and
Grandpa and cousins and get to do cool
stuff
okay little boys it's gonna be hard
leaving these little boys behind
I'm gonna miss you tell me you sad about
Nathan I love you buddy it's gonna be
okay you'll see him we'll get a Skype
with him okay and he'd been able to
unfortunately eat soup imagine to the
surrender welcomed in Nevada
Tommy's a hundred eight degrees outside
hey guys I can see Las Vegas we're
almost here Tommy
man it's been six hours in the car
you've done really well some guy took my
bags and I sincerely hope he works for
the hotel otherwise our trip just got
really expensive more promising how cool
is that
give this sit in the massive deep tub
eating pizza watching the fountain and
fireworks on the fourth of July
Tommy you're lucky boy you know that
this ain't too bad though eating a fresh
roll with honey butter are the balcony
early in the morning tommy's laughs
don't shoot way out here I'm going to
Battlefield Vegas we're gonna be
shooting some guy
yeah check that out
slowly back up I want to shoot that
displacement it's if you like guns this
is the stuff man I want to check outside
here you know this place actually rents
the tank and for like $3,000 or
something you can rent the tank and then
drive over a car
hey guys check it out I'm in a Huey oh
ho ho this is like a legit Museum here
yeah it's kind of nice guy you come in
and check in guys get all your guns and
ammo ready and then they paid you with
this little thingamajiggy when you're
ready and you can just take out all the
tanks and everything while you wait all
right guys it's go time
[Music]
they built that machine guns automatic
all the time the longer you trigger the
better oh that's just what they call a
saw like the squad operated weapon kind
of thing
I use a little peep sight okay
front sight hard upwards squeeze on that
trigger okay
3:30 at 6:30 yacht six-volume actor shot
a bolt action 30 I'd say this is gonna
be way better
that is one of my favorite weapons here
haha this is gonna be awesome
three two one
I knew it's gonna be cool that was
cooler than I thought so we're gonna go
do the vault tour
holy mackerel
look at that oh that's anti I almost got
that well that's the anti tank one right
it's the lobby Oh virginal chamber in
twenty millimeter ours is chambered in
fifty yeah I just finished my rounds
this is awesome guys guys look
definitely you got to check out
battlefield Vegas if you have two
minutes to rub together in Las Vegas
check this place out I'll put a link in
the description to their details their
website is that cool Tommy that's from a
machine gun
we go back oh we're getting close you
ready to race go Saudi Grendel's so I'm
really excited for this Becca's gonna
get a drive a race car but the funny
part about this whole thing is six
months ago my dear sweet wife suffered a
serious nerve injury giving birth to our
youngest child because of that she has
not been allowed to drive for six months
this will be your real your first real
driving experience in six months won't
it yeah way to jump in the deep end of
the pool baby
the Dodge Charger Hellcat I believe
[Music]
[Music]
couple Ferraris oh look another Ferrari
so we'll go do a couple laps around
watch red drive drives in back and you
ready to go fast Becky you're making
helmet so sexy right now
classy let's go
remember Becca remember everything we
learned from watching Ricky Bobby just
go like the wind I'm so glad to see her
doing this I was so worried she wouldn't
be able to get behind the wheel you know
it doesn't matter how fast she goes as
long as she's having fun I think she's
having a ball
[Music]
[Laughter]
there there's mom an adorable slow white
speck in the horizon
[Music]
holy mackerel
[Music]
there we go cuz that allows the fun
you look great out there babe you guys
have a good time all right well we need
to get head into Los Angeles we got a
plane to catch lot of a desert top here
we are in Baker California in the Mojave
Desert and it is a hundred and nine
degrees outside let's go outside pump
some gas we just drove past the world's
tallest thermometer unfortunately it's a
rental one invited them to dine with us
there's a crazy fire over there five
hours later we're in LA baby alright go
get checked in all right get you ready
for bed bud well good morning and
welcome to another beautiful day we are
going to Japan today I am so excited
aren't you presenting at a conference in
Japan yes are you ready oh yeah I'm
gonna do my presentation on the plane
distracted you think you can sit next to
all of this and not get distracted come
on Tom your boots on we're gonna get
frame is there your boots put your boots
on boots boots boots just put your boots
put your boots on foods it's like this
every time
check it out it's the beach oh yeah
that's the Pacific Ocean well we put our
foot in the Pacific Ocean Tommy's got
himself sandy and wet and we found a
shell for mommy I think it's time to go
to the airport
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wake up wake up wake up tell me you back
there made it to Osaka we've got to get
over to Kyoto it's about an hour and
change away
I'm tired and we're here finally
let's see you oh let's check this place
out okay so we got the game card
you gotta take your shoes off in a
Japanese house look at this table yeah
that's called the co-taught set so that
little tables yeah so check it out guys
we've got a modern Japanese toilet here
it comes with a control panel it's the
bidet feature there's the high powered
but cleaning and this is sets the
temperature so if you want warm water to
clean your butt well we got our so
settled in I'm gonna go out and get some
food for the family
there you go guys that's a moss burger
right there it's like barbecue sauce
mayonnaise a veggie patty and some
tomato or you can get the pork cutlet
burger which is deep fried pork cutlet
with shredded cabbage nice it has been a
long couple days but we are here in
Japan good night everybody
and we just sleep mama can explore the
city a little bit
that is the skin of a cicada
no no it's friendly hey Tom you see what
that is that's a turntable you park your
car on it and it spins around and lets
you turn it around does that feel good
nuts conceal a really good Apple
yeah that's that's $5 that's five
dollars and fifty cents for two apples
yeah yeah we don't need to buy tons of
them oh I remember these these a little
peanut sandwiches I love you get one for
you
[Music]
there are there it is open this up and
you get this little plunger here take
the plunger out and it pushes this
marble that's blocking the hole like a
cork pushes it down into the bottle and
then there's this marble sitting in
there see how you can see this marble
traditional original flavor Romani
tastes a little bit like a sprite but
different definitely different but it's
the closest thing to compare it to the
peanut butter sandwich
it's bread I lived in southern Japan for
two years as a missionary for the Mormon
Church and I've been back to visit one
time with Becca one of the best times of
my life fun walking by everyone's houses
you see lots of interesting danger most
of the houses here have a fire bucket
full water on the front porch yeah see
there's their fire bucket there's the
fire bucket there's the fire bucket
another fire buckets fire bucket a
statue of a priest this little
neighborhood shrine people will burn
incense there and put a little offerings
there flowers or sake or little treats
then they ring the bell and say a prayer
hey look at the dabbing cat see tell me
this is what mama watch
well they're gonna play there okay don't
drop it don't drop it yeah we get one
for you mr. prokey so you get one of
these careful there you go Tony - is
hello and Ohio is good morning your
vocabulary is growing it isn't a
croquette it's like a deep-fried pastry
usually with some sort of meat or curry
filling or something so I didn't read
that carefully what was in there so Oh
looks like it's got a curried egg inside
so we drink the romani and Tommy wants
the marble out so unscrew that and then
give it a good there you go I'm feeling
a little grimy after that - by whole
block and so I'm gonna take a bath -
check this out in the Japanese bath the
tubs are not for cleaning they're for
soaking and relaxing you wash here the
shower area and then if you want to take
it bath you soapy the tub after you've
cleaned yourself well guys after
breakfast and one of the most luxurious
showers of my life the family I are
going to go and hit the church which
will be interesting because to have
another three members of this household
don't speak Japanese that well so what's
gonna be interesting we're here at
church I'll see you in a little bit
well I got myself changed into some
company clothes and we're about to go
out sightseeing but I was thumbing
through the homes instruction manual and
I saw this great tutorial on how to use
a potty well I'm excited to go out on a
walk with my lovely wife oh my god I
mean I'm exhausted hey leave that Tom
yeah there's the toji temple you see him
we're here in a ramen shop and get some
croquet Joseph's and hopefully Tommy
won't pass out he's passed out all right
we got some Gilles and Oh Tommy zonked
out he's so tired he fell out of his
chair and hit his head and then probably
won't come up he dropped his soda glass
and broke it all over the place
poor guys exhausted let's get him to bed
but welcome to another beautiful day I
get mama some food and you get a bicycle
or something yeah it's a moat
alright guys we just riding our bikes I
see a Shimano sign a bunch of pictures
of fish it's a fishing store at sidious
I check it out that's a yield trap right
there
this place is awesome it's nice lady
here's telling me that the river has
catfish in it and so she sold me some
stuff for catfish and I'm gonna get
myself a license and see what happens so
check it out this is called guilt
talking
they can put a little ink on the fish
you catch you press it down on the paper
then the way of preserving your fish
kind of taxidermy
that's pineapples you want to try that
[Music]
alright
pineapples Bondar yeah hold onto that
there you go that's like ice cream
cotton candy the watermelon code
you like that watermelon flavored
popsicle with chocolate seeds
this fishing shop take us out we got a
big old fishing store here this is this
is what we're looking for
look at the size of these floats look at
these it's bigger than Tommy yeah look
at that all rod cases look at that that
is gonna be expensive lure these are the
telescopic landing as these are awesome
no booster seat ready like a big boy
do you think tom is that cool samurai
armor
and that's a samurai sword they got the
Kindle stuff okay
yeah is that cool that's $390 cool
that's how cool that is
hello give me good no you're gonna
Kendall baby are you attacking me are
you
now Tommy do you want to go up to the
top more moving stairs
yeah we're getting up pretty high aren't
we these escalators are just like crazy
tall Tommy alright eleven stories of
escalators later I think we're at the
roof you want to go up to the very roof
Tom there you go fun little view all
right time you wanna get a peach
smoothie okay we'll get a peach smoothie
getting some shish kebob for lunch this
is so cool Nathan's gonna love this
let's go try another fishing store
well your app town those are for
sharpening knives oh my goodness that's
beautiful wow that's beautiful
Wow hey do you think carpet but I think
it's a pick a room fish bunker that is
awesome
all right so we're buying a couple rods
reels the rod bag I have an addiction I
admit that here why don't you show mommy
your samurai sword okay Tommy yakiniku
then let's do it guys aki meku plays and
it's a buffet and we're supposed to
select what we want off this menu
unfortunately my abilities read kanji or
the Chinese characters
[Music]
was great well your name is matzah you
keep masaaki yuasa Yuki
Mizuki it'll be pizza
they're gonna help us out we're gonna do
some japanese-style fish in here alright
let's go fishing jumping all over the
place yeah we're here at the fishing
spot and we're gonna fish for something
called an igloo there we go
now we waiting look at the size of that
he gets on the camera I'll have to throw
it away and buy a new one
look at these guys they're hooking me up
man I got myself an awning even so only
give you these little ball of rice
covered in seaweed usually with the
surprise inside salmon who this one has
salmon inside only give me time
[Music]
tell me you want to reel this one in
fish is taking full power yeah it's her
first me going
yeah it's a pirate knee going because
he's missing an eye that makes him a
pirate are goes Oh guys this is awesome
those fish fight hard and they're really
a great fish and we're just having a
kick in the pants I think you've been on
the side
what pound line the way out holy
mackerel that is a big car is my first
Japanese car leave it on yes that's a
nice car that is a beautiful Japanese
car we're gonna hop in the car go up to
a different spot and try a different
species of fish that's when we know
we've been successful Lake Biwa thing is
beautiful and massive
look at all over the bride's field yeah
so right now we're at another bridge
right here next to a farm field we've
got a little stream that dumps in and
has carved out a little deep spot there
and we're gonna fish for tanaga look at
that that looks like a daze that is cool
all right
that is my first time how a moose ooh
Cao Lu su that's look at this hook this
looks like a size 26 maybe a little bit
of blood worm on it some split shot and
here's my bobber check that out isn't
that cool cuz it's got the black on it
yeah oh that's beautiful
well that is species number four and
five so five species of fish today look
at this isn't this beautiful
[Music]
oh he's green nice male
so we can't lose your frog way to go
tommy's the frog catching champion come
on Tommy
no more frogs go getting tired all right
guys we're gonna try to catch a Japanese
catfish now they look a little bit like
a wels catfish a little bit eel like we
are tired we are sweaty and I think it's
time to get this boy home but we had a
great time guys thank you very much
[Music]
today me and Tommy we're gonna do a lot
of sightseeing and we're gonna get some
breakfast you hungry yeah
yeah let's go on a bike for us brakes
ooh there you go two and a half dollar
peach okay tell me this is spaghetti and
chicken nuggets you want that spaghetti
and chicken nuggets and rice
all right let's get you one of those and
go get me an onigiri tell me you want to
see a samurai castle that's gonna be
pretty cool Nijo castle or nijo-jo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
look at that that is huge it's the time
are you happy with that you like that
well that shave ice and rest hit the
spot
Tommy only hurt himself twice but we got
to chat with some very nice people from
Kyoto at a misting tunnel to cool us off
mmm I'm getting wetter cuz I'm taller
[Music]
gon show oh gosh all of us sir
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tell me you have a core fund now well we
knocked out the Emperor's Palace in like
30 minutes we're gonna go hit the gion
district really quick here we are in the
Gilliam district we're gonna go get a
rickshaw for about an hour tour and
we're about to make a very nice Japanese
man work very very hard
let's see I saw your mother son dr.
Seuss in Juarez Kodomo Virginia no Hoda
soon dear Emma so oh this is a Shinto
shrine and this one is is for people who
are trying to quit bad habits green tea
started started here so they brought the
tea tree from China
Kyoto's a very famous for its green tea
because of that
you are
how many times Tommy
part trillion take it take it easy dumb
yeah I thought a rickshaw driver
recommended this place for yaki Siletz
we're gonna give this a shot I love me
some yakisoba
what do you watchin over there that is
proper yaki Silva right there I've been
missing that Becca's off to her
conference and I got Tommy here and we
are gonna go to Otto schema alright got
a parking spot for our bicycle let's get
on the train now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't touch him remember don't pick him
up don't touch him Tom they'll bite
[Music]
those clothes
one monkey was scratching his bottom
just like you
[Applause]
here you want to go down to the
playground tom hey you let me go I'll be
go fast okay well just go normal to be
dinner no let's find a rickshaw maybe go
do a little sightseeing all right we
need to use the bathroom here before you
hit the rickshaw and there we go there's
the bathroom do I go first down up you
go buddy Suzy disco doll selenium eto oh
boy oh then boobs in Mesquite that's
pretty time old temple built by the
Shogun Tokugawa Shogun and not a single
nail in there
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that rickshaw ride was fun we had a good
time
okonomiyaki si
check it out we got some yakisoba here
and we got okonomiyaki it's a pancake
kind of like thing only it's got like
cabbage and vegetables and egg and
ginger and meat in there it's a real owl
and you can touch him no no you gotta
totally bite me that's a barn house
that's from Virginia I don't think I
want to try this one
nope nope not trying that one easy who
touch me let's do in say hello hello my
name is Tommy the owl alright we're
doing it we're getting the flatly
overpriced talking animals
look at these umbrellas there's samurai
swords see get a pretty handkerchief for
Mom
good times
well good morning I'm going fishing
and I only have an hour to before Tommy
and Becca wake up and we're going to do
some more sightseeing but it's beautiful
day not too hot yet good feeling about
today
I'll tell you what these river carps
sure our Phi C's not a very big boy but
man he put up a fight
there we go off you go
I'm gonna fall in here well it's 8:00 in
the morning and I'm already a big ball
of sweat but it was totally worth it
me and Tommy are going to cruise around
to the gion district don't have a lot of
plans so we have some fun
[Music]
so being Tom stopped a pharmacy to pick
up some sunscreen because you know we
kind of need it and I bought this stuff
it's sunscreen plus cooling which sounds
good but I think it just got menthol in
it now my face feels like it's both cold
and burning at the same time it's like I
was mere icy hot in my eyes
[Music]
me and Becca have a tradition every time
we go to a foreign country we pick up a
kids book we need to do that too so I'm
gonna start hitting bookstores see if we
can find something
we got an antique Japanese A's book
about a mythological baby that rides a
bear and has a giant battle ax that
seemed pretty cool to me
so this right here is one of the biggest
show 10th of her Bennett's a little west
of the healing district and it's pretty
awesome nice store look at that there's
like a bearded cleaver
that's the eagle no coming either those
are axes and look at those sheaves okay
I think I ended up buying out half the
story
all right well we found a little place
to eat here you've got some orchid dawn
and beef curry give a track you ready
bud nice so this is rice and beef curry
salad and this is oyakodon which is egg
and chicken on rice listen pickled
vegetables and we've got a little soup
here as well so anyway so coming under
my own on this car chotto chotto docket
are you going
because commit a grave ah no wider no no
no wired2fish
a year Oh Mac who's suing okay from the
hatchery hatchery jargon bad day
hmm that was a long trip we did a lot of
bike riding where'd you go meet mama at
the Convention Center and trying to get
some food for her hey yeah well let's go
hit the tories yeah we've got some you
don't for you well here you guys alright
fushimi inari shrine and we're gonna go
see the thousand please we're gonna see
like ten of them and clap from
exhaustion and give up and go home but
still alright guys so this is a toilet e
it's right there it's associated with
Shinto and the Shinto shrines have them
the Buddhist temples have a different
type of gate but if you see this its
Shinto this corridor of toady's
apparently goes over quite some ways you
can do make a real big hike out of it we
are grossly out of shape beca's recently
recovered crippled and Tommy is whining
so that's gonna cut our journey short
that's okay we're having fun
I know you talked to yaki here only a
semester see it's not mayonnaise and
bonitas flakes what's not to like
here we are at Kyoto tower we're gonna
try to get to the very top if we can
[Music]
[Music]
there's our house I'm gonna head home by
taxi gonna eat some food listen to our
book relax guys it's another beautiful
morning
I'm sitting here on the bridge above my
fishing spot getting a bird's-eye view
so I'm gonna drive around and try a few
different places and see if I can't
catch and carp with bread on the surface
look at that
nutria right down there aviators caps
the kamikazes would were made out of
nutria they're brought to Japan for that
[Music]
look at that another beautiful Japanese
common carp well guys I got time for one
more fish than I should be getting home
and I think that one more fish is right
here
oh here he goes he's gonna so take that
what the area
I touched him so it counts and I got my
hook back that's a win okay maybe one
more fish just just one more fish oh
there yeah
[Music]
oh well this really better be my last
car I gotta get going home I know my
wife ditches to do some sightseeing so
I'm gonna put this guy back but all this
has been so much fun at all all right
this is Osaka second biggest city in
Japan
tell me where you see the same right yes
once you saw a little fish attack the
turtle that's cool
[Music]
so this is the main power the main cast
we're one side kicking up sweaty man
very do you need to take the elevator or
there's no line to take the stairs 100
degree heat everyone's taking the
elevator to the top of the castle nice
view
what does that boat down there and can
you go fishing that's what I want to
know
yeah the giant carp right there
[Music]
only got a samurai sword
[Music]
I don't know hey buddy come on over here
[Music]
alright now it's pretty awesome Tommy
got his photo taken in the little
samurai costume it is hot and humid and
there's a weight on my shoulder hey
Tommy Tommy wait a minute wait a minute
look at this yeah he didn't pee himself
I wet his pants not the other way around
Oh Tommy has taken to making farting
noises in the back of taxis okay guys
wha I'm in here oh no soccer with my
good friend mr. Sato also known as Tokyo
we go way back when I was meeting him
we're in our 20s we were missionaries in
future together janta he looks exactly
the same because he's Japanese and will
never age check this place out they've
got minion gym base that's cute
that's that's cute
[Music]
three feet you want dad okay
[Laughter]
oh yeah we got our Dragon Ball Z shirt
sweat tell hmm
I'm pretty excited to see what happens
it is crazy crowded in there we've been
waiting to get in because of course the
Japanese people are wonderful and they
appreciate a restaurant where you can
catch and fish for your own dinner all
of these fish and tanks here and they
rent you fishing poles and you pay for
bait and they're going to catch it and
then you they charge you based on how
you have it caught this place is awesome
all right that is a good-looking baited
hook right there sumimasen don't see
today that he wants congee is going for
the big boy go for it Tom alright bye
Harold yeah these guys are not
see if you can snag one
[Music]
oh good job buddy that is the big tie me
pagina Toyota that's his pink zebra
right there that's a sushi style party
top
[Music]
you tell me you like your sushi
[Music]
wait what do you think it didn't taste
fishy doesn't doesn't taste bad does it
all right you're gonna try some of this
this pink sea bream sushi here I
remember you good okay so they want to
get some tempura so they're gonna try to
catch fish with this basket thing
[Music]
it's all we need Tommy let's go back to
the dinner table all right let's go
those okay these are the little Jascha
fish we caught a little silver ones in
the basket and it's at moments like this
I realized I don't know where my child
is
it's kinda like eating a herring that
was pretty awesome that was about 250
bucks which all of us eating that much
fresh seafood is it too bad actually
guys I've got a belly full of fresh fish
and we have had a great time this is a
great chance to catch up with some good
friends and just have a ball you guys
want to take this out if you're ever in
Osaka check it out
foodie kitty fairly well rested from a
late night of partying we're gonna head
back to Osaka and to go to church with
my friends and a little bit well we just
finished up with church and we're here
with the Sato family and we're going to
go back and party at their place I mean
what do you think of the muita
you like it I do it I don't
oh look at this
that's that was a much younger man right
there look at that that doesn't even
look like me Oh beautiful
this plant I don't know what it's called
but they boil the leaves and they make
the juice out of it well yeah sure
enough look it is right there oh look at
that we got some fresh vegetables for
dinner here that's pretty cool very good
leader this is a beautiful meal Josie
are you are you taking that corn come
here
I bet you were having fun
because I'm like uh I'm gonna do the key
thing is bad omen Texas Hallisey good
morning guys welcome to our last day in
Japan oh it's a little sad though I do
miss my two little boys that are with
Grandma and Grandpa I hope so oh man I'm
sad to leave what a fun trip and I think
one of the best parts is listening to
Tommy say domo arigato gozai a moustache
to everybody nailed it we're going all
the way this number 49 well it's been
about 11 hours and we're just about to
land in LA
where's my boys who wants to see
presents check this out it's a talking
owl look at take a look at your gym day
you look so little Jacob it is gym babe
with little frogs on it it's a peek at
two fishing rods you know these are
people do you like them are they cool
okay tomorrow morning we're gonna get to
swordfight but tonight we gotta get
ready for bed it's past your bedtime
hey little Jacob good morning are you
ready for breakfast one of the things I
missed the most about the USA is
American breakfast I am pretty exhausted
but we're gonna go fishing are we guys
all right guys we're here at Willow Park
and Murray Utah
come here get a fish come here
whoa come on fighter buddy put your back
into it okay you get stuff really neat
whoo all right David there you go buddy
beautiful top doing good dog
all right time that's enough really now
just walk it backwards walk it backwards
[ __ ] all right there we go ah yeah it's
the longest one is the biggest one we've
had so far
nose whiskers on him yeah
[Music]
I think all right guys come on up well
we got the kids to bed at it's 1 p.m.
[Music]
here we are in the top of Snowbird the
boys want to ride the chairlift down the
mountain with me and we need to measure
them to see if they're the required 42
inches their tariff closes in like 10
minutes and we got to make it down this
mountain
we got a fat old man and an ambitious
little boy and we're gonna see if we can
get down there before he gets stuck we
got two minutes dumb two minutes we can
do it I'm dying
go find your dog in the hold on you lose
your mama that's mommy
grandma grandpa there thank I wants to
try the little mountain coaster and the
zipline thing for Giggy so where you go
see we can't hunt down good job buddy
we're gonna put the kids to bed I'm
gonna put myself to bed and I'll wake up
a little bit more energized tomorrow mmm
we're gonna get some breakfast well I
got breakfast squared away let's go
fishing
we're good clothes there that's where
the water used to be look at that guy's
there's about 12 or 15 carp right there
just tons of them nice little common car
congratulations Nathan you like that was
that fun all right let's let him go
shall we
aye Nathan Nathan you got one okay you
guys in your crazy double all right
there we go
Hey
another great another great little
common carp there another nice little
mirror carp I think we better get them
home here in a little bit plus we have a
long drive back back to the house oh
wait a minute is that your diaper oh
wait a minute you're naked okay
Nathan's going full nudists on us but
you're naked did you guys have a fun
time oh good all right let's go get you
guys some food my wife's brother Matt
Uncle Matt is visiting here and I think
we're lucky the boys will talk him into
some kendo sword fighting
[Music]
yeah uncle Matt's a good sport for
letting you sword fight with him now
you'll get these packed up we're leaving
tomorrow all right we gotta get these
kids to bed I'm tired well we're sitting
here packing up and we have a little bit
of a big moment here Jacob started
saying mama yeah this is a big get for
Becca because Tommy's first word was
fish and his second word was data and
then several months later mama
[Music]
Tommy how hungry are you
[Music]
Garamond any kind of nostalgic every
time I come to this Airport because I
remember working on the construction of
this Airport terminal it's the Sun is
just barely set welcome to Alaska are
you glad to see Michael Curtis it's is
he your favorite we've got to get to bed
so I will pick this up tomorrow morning
you might go over to grab on grandpa's
place well everyone else takes their
time so we got a good chunk of the
family here in the car and we're gonna
go out to breakfast it oh yeah yeah at
the king salmon that's whale baleen that
goes inside the mouth of whales the 1964
earthquake my parents were here when
this happened yeah
sourdough pancakes reindeer sausage we
pick up a bonus nickels Asian selfie hi
[Music]
[Music]
look at this swarm of nickels and R
appellees here we are gonna descend upon
this place gommi
behave yourself but the musk ox will eat
you light feel free to pass it around
and feel how light it is there's no
shortage well let's go get some ice
cream
shall we guys
[Music]
I like candy like that is that good man
I am tired
apparently the boys are too because
there was some epic meltdowns on the way
home yeah I'm tired I'm tired but you
know we're gonna just take it easy eat
with the family have some hamburgers and
just enjoy a beautiful day well guys
it's 9:30 at night the kids are in bed
it's late and I'm going to sleep
it's a beautiful Sunday morning and
we're getting all dappered up and ready
to go to church I'm staying here with my
sister and she's introduced me to
chocolate marshmallow mateys
never has getting diabetes been so fun
[Music]
I'm gonna turn off the camera because
apparently v-log in the worship service
is frowned upon
we'd like me to bring you out your stake
in tater tots well I got myself a very
unhealthy lunch here I'm gonna hang out
let the kids play a little bit then
we're gonna go visit my grandparents and
introduce them to Jacob this is great
grandpa is that a toy box I remember
this I used to play with this when I was
a little little kid oh say goodbye guys
[Music]
so Tommy and Nathan are hanging out with
the cousins here and the field and
they're playing tiger attack kids are
already up and playing with cousins and
today's a little bit of a question mark
day we've got a big family picnic
celebrating my parents 50th wedding
anniversary but the rest of the day is
kind of up in here
me and my brother-in-law Curtis here
we're gonna see if we can't defeat the
foe challenge you even have to sign a
waiver I'm at least 18 resident the
United staes good physical and mental
health you should have like a back brace
if you carry in that oh crap
you know it's actually really tasty pho
so in case you don't know what fun is
it's a viet knees dish and it usually
has lots of different types of meat
usually pork or beef and you have bean
sprouts you have Thai basil green onions
limes there's this really yummy sweet
brown sauce you put in there that's good
or if you like it little spicy you can
put a little sriracha sauce in there I
don't worry about winning at this but I
wasn't worried about not shaming myself
some pack the food just watching this
guys I'm really full I'm starting to
fight that will regurgitate and reflex
me swallowing things twice smiling on
the outside but I'm crying on the inside
[Music]
if you were ever in Anchorage and you
want to try the ultimate challenge and
look for me and Curtis photo up here on
the wall right there right there watch
the big grouse right there 6:30 in the
morning I just woke up my brother and
we're going salmon fishing
oh there you my trout rat rod hooked me
a silver here holy smaller yeah
beautiful though there's beautiful trout
nope there we go
long nose sucker that man that looks a
lot like an ego in Japan pick him up Tom
no oh really big Tom what you really see
what happens I'm just washing oh you got
away sorry buddy Nathan are you stuck
alright let me get you out Nathan you're
muddy is that better
well guys we caught about 15 to 20
rainbow trout two or three Dolly Varden
we caught three white fish and a
Silver's we're gonna call it a day get
him back to the cabin warm him up
Tommy you feeling better
Nathan do you feeling better buddy come
here and grab daddy Nathan you've been
picking your face again
oh we're taking family photos in an hour
mom's gonna kill you and maybe me too
all right guys you're ready to go hiking
with the cousins
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're here at Hatcher's past Alaska
near the independence goldmine
come on Nathan you got a walk it's
pretty cool this is gorgeous
[Music]
we used to come up here as Boy Scouts
and we would camp and this makes no
caves in the wintertime and then the day
times we take your slow climb up the
side of the mountain it's let down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
man check out this view that's pretty
cool
I know not the butt crack Oh ice wedge
II hiked all the way up there and back
if you want to do this hike it's gold
chord Lake Trail
Nathan you look a little wet and dirty
[Music]
[Music]
when I was a little kid we used to camp
up here and I remember we snuck in to
those buildings they weren't collapsed
back then
yeah it's cold in here isn't it yeah
there's the door to the mine it's all
gated out I've even babysitting Jacob
yeah look at this plenty fit back here
this is perfect you're a sports utility
baby so many happy memories growing up
here but tomorrow morning we're getting
on a plane heading to British Columbia
yeah
[Music]
oh yeah look at those two for that
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
we're all the girls we're in the car
we're on the road
Alexa isn't here right now there's no
Alexa here there's no like so we don't
even know Canada
that's that's a national anthem a
hundred we gonna go a hundred just
kilometres up like 60 look at this view
not too shabby yeah it does taste like
saltwater so I better get him to bed
though and get some sleep cuz we got a
long day tomorrow it's gonna be a lot of
fun
[Music]
morning guys did you sleep well
there you go can you guys both fit in
there don't worry buddy
all right let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
there we go you like their ice cream
see the $1 coins gotta loon on it and
this is a $2 coin so it's a loony in a
toonie well this is how I like to see a
city like your hot dog this is serious
you doing good
[Music]
[Music]
all right everyone get your boots on
where he's gonna see mama well we are
out the door and almost out of the hotel
but one of us pooped his pants this is
where Becca's stand all right 20th for
getting off hey buddy
whoa look at that view
we got food stalls food truck concerts
magic shows lots and lots of people I am
exhausted how about you guys
they taught me is the back of my shirt
sweaty you guys wanna do a little hiking
all right little fun fact I used to
carve totem poles so take it out here
this pole I'm pretty sure is hyda which
is a tribe on an island a little bit
north of here and the pole over here to
Tommy's right I believe is Kwakiutl this
moves around a lot
good because I'm really fat there's a
whole bunch of people fighting Jesus
back there got it oh look at this we're
in like a giant tree fort look at that
we are we are legitimately high off the
ground
[Music]
[Music]
all right fat dead on the bridge well
that was fun but definitely crowded and
not cheap we got back up she's done with
her conference for the day and believe
this or not her birthday is coming up
soon captain mountains and the water and
the crazy kids in the back okay this is
gorgeous did you ask for better weather
to go up in a plane okay
pull that down okay these is this cool
Becca are you excited
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah fun beautiful amazing I loved it
that was awesome those are so awesome oh
yeah well guys we had a great time here
with glacier air a beautiful beautiful
sightseeing trip and way cheaper than
the other trips down in Vancouver so if
you guys want to check out more
information about glacier air here in
Squamish we'll go and put a link in the
description to check it out here we are
at the watershed grill rumor has it
that's a nice little place to grab some
food
they told us it was about a 15 to 30
minute wait for a table so we're sitting
here on a bench watching the river I
just saw the sunset not too bad he's one
of the best weights for a table I've
ever had come on buddy
up here so in a weird twist I bought
some butter chicken because you know
I've never eaten Indian food in Canada
before at the hotel and I just got the
bill it was shocking we're gonna go and
have some breakfast and then we're gonna
pack up the car and we're gonna get out
of here
are you picking your nose to celebrate
Becca's birthday I bought her three
different types of non-alcoholic
cocktails so we'll see what you think
and we got a rope quickly before the
kids get it we've got some Korean short
rib sliders and some tempura shrimp
rolls with some chili sauce on them and
Nathan's eating mac and cheese mostly
with his fingers I have a good birthday
big
[Music]
see
[Music]
so apparently campfires are banned
pretty much everywhere but I am
determined to eat our hotdogs so we're
gonna MacGyver this son of a gun as best
I can
[Music]
all right right behind the dipstick
seems to be the hot spot I think we give
it about 10-15 miles and it should be
perfectly cooked oh yeah that's the
stuff that's done you guys want s'mores
all right we got the s'mores sitting on
the engine block well let that sit for
about 10 minutes
more hmm there you go not a bad engine
blocks more look at that that's pretty
Nathan what do you think in this place
is cool you excited for tomorrow we're
gonna catch huge fish tomorrow okay
well we'll have a good night and we'll
see everyone in the morning good night
7:20 in the morning we are going
sturgeon fishing
excellent that is a northern pike minnow
aka Squamish there you go time we got a
northern pike meal you I catch a
sturgeon with him look at that good job
look at him
basically a live bait right there just
not real you got it it's not like carpet
no bow - I'm the real truth that's high
fives probably just a touch under six
foot that's 100 pound fish right there
sweet that's what we call a good start
yeah he's good to go just turn him
sideways you'll swim away
eight and a half foot probably 325 to
350 pounds well thanks very much that
welcome loads of fun I will see you
tomorrow morning
so your same bat time same bat place
your bet you get a bigger one
all right we'll do it are you ready to
go swimming all right let's do it
all right guys this is the cool you want
to go swimming or take your boots off
take your boots up guys do you just want
me to drag you into the water yeah okay
what's got you you're holding on to me
you're touching the bottom yeah
hello Nathan so cute what I'm gonna do
when he grows up
[Music]
we're gonna need a bigger boat yeah
oh he put up a strong fight pushing the
current so Steve just told me that that
sturgeon right there the one we just
landed was the 50th fish they've caught
this year it was eight feet or longer
that's insane
I'll put a lot more information the
Steve Cal's guide service sturgeon
hunter calm I'll put it in the
description if you guys want to see more
information all right Steve thanks again
to the pleasure
all right Nathan head back to the car or
I'm going to have to I'm gonna have to
beat you with a stick run I'm gonna eat
you
Oh Nathan you better catch up with Tommy
I'm coming for you my back is sore
reeling in eight sturgeon in two days a
lot of work let's go get mommy and Jacob
oh you smell so much better than I do
family's all back together
shall we go to the beach oh look at all
these blackberry bushes well look at a
ton of em hmm
well they got rose hips over there look
at this this is gorgeous
thank I found you a clam now do you know
how to look for live clams not just dead
ones look for a hole in the sand see
right here see this hole scary hole in
there oh there he is see him chase you
always a crab you found a little crab
[Music]
look what I found its legs tell you that
shandar see it's pushing for 30 and we
need to get it into a hotel and get
these boys showered I haven't had a
shower and more days than I like to
admit I carry him back last hotel stay
of the trip
doesn't matter where in the world you go
or how much money you Stan
the cart the kids the enjoy the most is
playing in the food seven pieces have
checked luggage two strollers and about
four carry-ons to simply check my
rearview mirror oh yeah love you baby
the house is burned down that's good we
are home it's about 2:30 in the morning
and it feels good to be home hopefully
you guys have enjoyed coming along for
the ride it is make sure to click like
let me know you like it thanks for
watching guys I'm gonna go get some
sleep it's been a long month if you
liked this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor boys YouTube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
Subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for watching